they prayed first but their intent to
protest was evident
it wasn't long before they marched and
denounced the imminent visit of the
prime minister narendra modi
led by some of kolkata's leading
activists and religious leaders
the general public poured onto the
streets in their thousands
winding their way through calcutta's
busy shopping district
the ruling party's chief minister mps
and civil society have not confirmed
whether they're meeting the prime
minister
as he comes to celebrate the 150th
anniversary of the deep sea port
they're all objecting to the citizenship
law which was passed in december
seen as unjust and divisive the
government
is completely rattled that you can see
because
there's no end there is no leadership no
central leadership
people are calling their own but in
every single one of them you see hindus
and muslims together waving the national
flag
demanding that we won't allow us to be
divided so it's a very
particular kind of movement as i said i
have not seen such a movement
since mahatma gandhi death
but it doesn't end there this park is
hosting one of the many peaceful but
noisy protests
that have been continuing through the
week and in different parts of calcutta
and as day turns to night the voices of
protesters continue to be heard loud and
strong
across the city this particular
gathering of several hundred has been
ongoing for four consecutive nights
and their numbers are growing they've
come from all sections of society
many of them women recovering from
surgery usma jameel a housewife
feels strongly about the government's
moves to alienate muslims and other
minorities
and asked her friends and neighbours to
join her in this local park
to demonstrate before modi arrives each
evening this week
it's grown and morphed into a major
focal point for anti-government
sentiment
i hope the government understands we
reject the citizenship laws
we'll never submit our paperwork and we
look forward to the supreme court
hearing
because every indian is focused on that
date and our hope
is that those laws will be thrown out
across india people have taken to the
streets the parks and universities
to voice their discontent with laws they
perceive as injust
and racist here in calcutta they're
being led on a chilly winter evening
by a first-time activist usma rallied to
the cause with no other aim but to face
for her
an unjust law that could determine her
very existence
and that of millions of others across
india
sahil rahman al-jazeera calcutta